so everybody's talking about it the
valent beta is out and it's looking to
be one of the biggest launches for an
eSports game ever and yet another major
eSports league is looking to franchise
the lck the League of Legends league in
Korea they're looking to pull the
trigger on franchising in 2021
so sticking with League of Legends there
seems to be trouble in paradise since
Dignitas has given hooni permission to
look for other teams to play with and
this upcoming summer split and after
years of confusion around the topic
twitch have finally come up with a
concrete policy regarding clothing and
nudity on Street all right so let's talk
balint the closed beta dropped on April
7th and it is all anybody is playing I
mean Keith you open twitch and every
single streamer that I follow is playing
this game yeah I mean it had a huge
release I mean yesterday was basically
the first day everyone was streaming it
and you're talking about 1.7 million
peak viewers for the game and twitch
broke its own record for leadership
across the platform which was obviously
spearheaded by Ballard with more than 4
million viewers it is clear that this
game is popping off in an unprecedent
way so they still pushing up yep yeah
there's Zink god damn they just they all
just W keep me
i poisoned draw you did not kill that
guy that's swung on me in lane I may
have never played this game with you
ever again bro so this game seems to
really be landing well on Twitch Devon
would have been some of the initial
impressions that you've seen so I think
one of the first things that came to
mind from me was that when we first
started hearing about this game that
people were talking about it
one of the big comparisons was overwatch
right the colorful characters and the
abilities and things like that but from
what I was watching yesterday watching
you know cloak and tin the tap man and
nothing this is really a a hardcore
first-person shooter if you don't know
how to aim and click heads you're kind
of screwed yeah I mean I think you know
after the first sort of wave of content
that came out after their little Valerie
retreat shroud made that point pretty
heavily right he said look if you guys
think this is overwatch or tf2 it's not
you know this isn't a csgo style game
and I think we're seeing that from these
characters right they're not using their
abilities to shoot you when you walk
around the corner with a giant laser
beam a lot of those abilities are
supplementary to the aiming that we've
come to love that of games like csgo
they use these abilities as utility as
flashes and you Mali's and smokes and I
think it's kinda landed pretty well on
both the hardcore FPS community and your
twitch streamers and content creators
Dennis don't let them talk to you this
way I believe in you literally sat in
the shadow for two years bro you can't
even say that what do you read you got
cursed by stump for eight years
Oh No so we've recently got the news
that the lck which is Korea's premier
division of League of Legends is gonna
be franchising for the 2021 season yeah
the best league in the world is finally
franchising China na and EU have already
done it now the lck is jumping in and
notably their system looks a lot more
similar to the China the LPL than na or
EU they're finishing this spring split
and then that'll be their last round of
relegation and then those teams that are
in the 2020 summer split it looks like
those will make up the roster slots for
this franchise version of the week
one of the interesting things that I saw
on Twitter keith was a article and
thread that kind of noted that as some
of the lck teams were not happy with the
announcement they felt like they were
kind of blindsided and weren't looped
into the conversation so that was just
kind of something interesting that I saw
coming out of all of this yeah I mean
there's this sentiment obviously that
there's gonna be a little bit less of
the Cinderella story of Korea right
you're not gonna have teams like the Rox
Tigers for Griffin if you can't come all
the way from Challenger and win the lead
that said there's obviously that
stability that comes with franchising
that you can't under so next to six
boats viper jump into the side finds the
final kill gets another one the devil
comes in is beyond responds but it's
just to see the nexus crumble and
Griffin have done it the 3-1 victory
comes through they delay MVPs hopes of
making it back into the lck but they
themselves have qualified for the summer
split welcome to the LC K for the first
time Griffin so after years of people
getting banned and complaining about
Twitch's opaque rules when it comes to
nudity on stream they finally released
new guidelines Keith yeah after a ton of
bannings and a ton of maybe should have
been banned we finally know what you can
and can't wear and how nude or not nude
you could be on Twitch yeah they talk
about these new guidelines in a pretty
clear and concise way I got to be honest
and one of the things they talked about
is that all of the rules that are going
to apply to actual human beings are
going to apply to Avatar channels like
the melody project for example yeah yeah
no more bot porn on Twitch yeah one of
the other things that is interesting in
this the new guidelines is the fact that
they have like exemptions for these new
rules right including swimming body art
breastfeeding which for a long time have
been a lot of what people have been
talking about when it comes to twitch
not being clear enough about what's
allowed and not allowed while streaming
so after a pretty lackluster split it
seems like Team Dignitas in their top
laner hooni are on the outs they've
actually given him permission to look
for another team to play with for this
upcoming summer split yeah I mean one of
the biggest personalities and probably
one of the best technical players in the
entire league well you know obviously
didn't have the best split with Dignitas
carries a big contract with him names
said hey man you want to go find a
better team to play with in the summer
feel free and also take your contract
with you or here comes the TPN once
again a five-on-five
an Akkadian a fruit on the front lines
when you're running on the side looking
upward
go away he's just instantly dead of his
book we had arranged so Keith I was
scrolling through read it a couple days
ago and I found this crazy story of this
guy who streams for a hundred and ninety
five hours straight on Twitch and he
actually broke the Guinness World Record
yeah yeah I heard about this too
basically what happened was every time
someone donated he would stream for two
more minutes and at first you know he
thought you know maybe I'll do a 24 hour
stream maybe it'll just be a slightly
elongated version of my normal streams
because this guy isn't that big but to
say it blew up into something a lot more
than that would be definitely an
understatement
yeah one of the funniest things is just
kind of how on the fly it is right so
the last people to hold this record is
actually Hulu and they had like their
full staff it was all pre-planned
everything was planned out but with los
Pollos TV the the streamer he was just
kind of like doing it randomly he was
like watching twitch clips that people
sent in he was playing video games from
time to time he took naps and like his
brother and his dad philbin and that was
honestly some of the funniest [__] just
because they're not like twitch endemic
people right one thing I saw on Reddit
the other day is that apparently this
this all ended pretty poorly what was
the deal with all yeah dude it was it
was terrible so he gets to 161 hours
breaks the record pop champagne on
stream with his dad missed the other
through the horn aid right and then at a
hundred and ninety five hours some
[__] DDoS attacked him kicked him
offline and then when he came back he
was like ranting about how he didn't
give a [__] cuz he already had the
record but it's a stupid thing to do
satisfaction we [__] beat the record
I don't give a [__] you can go [__]
yourself I mean this guy no matter what
he's he's the Ironman of twitch like
imagine imagine streaming for that long
your eyes would glaze over he started on
March 29th dude he was streaming until
like two days ago that's insane
everyone in the stream cool yeah just
got the email mother for urine I have I
possess valor oh me oh actually just
just because Devin's on the line me and
Shawn are gonna play some after this if
you're down you can write off yeah and
you bought diggin that brimstone guy
yeah yeah brimstone is my boy he's got
this like he has like a Molotov like a
Molly and he does this thing where he
pulls his gun out of his bag he goes
Molly and it's like so it's just fun
colleagues